all right let's go back to the phones a
lot of people want to get on today at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go let's talk to
Tim in the six three one Tim in the six
three one what's new with you Tim we
haven't heard from you in the new year
are you David hey what's up I just want
to give you a quick call to get your
take on the new on earth video that came
out the undercover video of a Bernie
Sanders staffer and Iowa talking about
how some supporters should be in quoted
being in putting gulags
and how gulags are a good thing and they
should be shown on the beach yeah I'm
against that I saw the video obviously
this is know you know this is know
Bernie strategist or anything like that
but I find that attitude I find what was
said absolutely denounce Abul and
deplorable you know in the United States
we have due process we don't put people
in prison or jail for political beliefs
and that is not something I can get
behind for sure that's good to hear
you know I seen Bernie Sanders career in
its own video that he has talked highly
of Fidel Castro's that tactus dealing
with dissidents against shooting them on
the beach and he is for that I want to
make sure I know yours you're saying
you've seen video of Bernie saying he
approves of shooting dissidents on a
beach with guns no no no no I said that
he promotes Fidel Castro and the Castro
family and their climb to power oh I
haven't heard Bernie I can't I'm not
saying he that that's not something he
said I'm just saying that I'm not aware
of him having said that okay well just a
data their interviews back in the 1980s
anyone can look them up and there's also
him stating that bread lines are a good
thing you know people either die in the
streets or rich which isn't
realistically plausible you know I don't
mean to keep interrupting you Tim but
you're talking so quickly that I want to
make sure your did you just say Bernie
said that he's fine with people either
being rich or dying in the streets no
the first part again I said he was fine
he likes bread lines he thinks bread
lines are a good thing
quote okay I've never seen him what what
the source of that is no if you if you
type in in YouTube and it's not censored
yet Bernie Sanders states that bread
lines are a good thing well who would
censor that what do you mean they in a
1988 interview I'm talking about YouTube
and Google algorithms is when you're
hold on you're saying that you know they
would search hold on a second Tim I'm
trying to understand yours you're saying
YouTube would make the video not
findable or they would delete the video
right I would say I'm not sure if it is
yet but they would maybe not delete the
video they would take it out of search
results so if you're typing in a search
bar in YouTube or Google because they're
basically the same thing at this point
they can remove that and put the
mainstream media up on top of that so
things from CNN things from Fox News
vice versa recommendations from Fox News
you've seen this I only get Fox News and
I hate it
you know the YouTube algorithm is
definitely designed to prop up certain
content and push down others that diet
that there's no I won't argue that at
all Tim so so what I'm saying is for
your audience and for you as well
because I'm not sure how you haven't
seen this is that he states that Bernie
Sanders states that bread lines are a
good thing in a country you know not
where you've seen the video I don't
agree more I would I would guess knowing
Bernie that there's more context than
you're providing that's my guess but
I'll review the video Tim I appreciate
you bringing it to my attention that
would be great and thanks for having me
on again David so we could talk with you
all right very good there is Tim let's
go next to our caller from the 949 area
code caller from 949 what's your name
where are you calling from this is
Daniel from Los Angeles hey Daniel what
part of LA you calling from
uh downtown LA actually downtown okay no
no I kind of like downtown I know it
gets a bad rap downtown is great we and
it's got really revitalized as long as
you don't mind walking past a bunch of
homeless shelters well yeah we talked
about that actually earlier this week
and and some of the policies that are
that are being considered there but in
this is your time not mine what did you
want to talk about today well I did want
to touch on the previous callers a
little conversation about the breadline
comment yeah the context that you were
looking for is that he was saying in
other countries people don't line up for
food the rich get the food and the poor
starve to death
so versus starving to death bread lines
are a good thing I see okay well that
isn't that is relevant context I would
say having to wait in live with regrets
seems better than starving to death
most definitely um the thing I wanted to
touch bases one on is there's all this
trial going on with Trump the
impeachment and there are a lot of
officials who are getting involved and
basically just blocking things and
trying to make it so there are no
witnesses there's no evidence reviewed
or anything like that right at what
point are these people I understand that
we're hoping that they'll be held
politically responsible in the upcoming
elections at one point does it get to
where they would be held criminally
responsible for aiding and abetting and
never president never right no no never
it that's this point yeah I mean listen
you know if you in in uh there are
people who would argue that that's a
good thing so the the one of the
prototypical examples is my home country
of Argentina where it is very common
that when you have a change of regime
the new regime will start will will will
assist in and will push for criminal
charges against members of the prior
regime and the thing is if you've done
something criminal
you should be there should be
consequences for that you should be held
accountable and of course the problem
becomes when it just becomes this circle
where every regime starts getting
indictments on the previous regime
nothing has ever resolved kangaroo
courts you know this it's a it's a
catch-22 situation because I want people
held accountable I've also seen what
happens when an administration simply
starts indicted members of the previous
one endlessly it's not particularly good
for the country because before you know
it the previous people are back in power
much like is happening in our
now so it's I don't know what the
solution is quite frankly well just to
follow on that point in regards to when
Obama got elected and decided that we
were going to look forward and not
prosecute people who were potentially
guilty of war crimes yeah who had just
left office was that a good decision
because I feel like that just was you
know encouraged a certain party to
continue down that line and at any time
to some degree any time one gets away
with something it is an it is a tacit
encouragement to do something again the
next time or it sets an example for
someone else to some degree obviously
the world is more complicated than that
but you have to balance right with would
if Obama says we're going to indict well
of course Obama couldn't couldn't say it
because he doesn't control the judiciary
but let's say the Obama administration
and his judiciary decided we're going to
investigate and indict george w bush on
war crimes if it's the right thing in
many cases but what happens in the
united states to the fabric of the
relationship between all of these
different branches i'm not saying it
wouldn't be warranted but where would we
be today if that had been done because
you know it was bush gonna go to prison
for that of course not so what do we
really it right by doing it i don't know
I want people held accountable but I
know that's not the way they're going to
be right that's a good point
well thank you for your time today too
David all right Daniel great to hear
from you appreciate it